Revenge yeah someone [ __ ] you over or
something like that and you had to get
revenge on them no
no that's what Tom told me I don't think
I really been doing that's what I told
you I was bartering cigarettes
cigarettes I gotta look today it was a
few times I don't know maybe it's
something I'm just not remembering but
no I can't take off hand that I ever
been in like real trouble and oh
maybe a cleaning utensil that you might
have used this is what happened this was
a [ __ ] from the street so what happened
was you know when you're selling drugs
there's always other drug dealing Crews
that y'all beef with so these [ __ ] was
another drug dealing crew like
and um
one time
um I went out to a nightclub and I just
got a little too drunk and I was just
having a little too much fun you know
and I went back to the hotel that we
were staying it was actually my little
brother homecoming you see she's
starting to get over there and [ __ ] so
we was like taking him out we got him a
hotel room and all that type of [ __ ] so
we went back to the hotel room
and just so happened as soon as I go
into the lobby the [ __ ] we beefing
with this is in the lobby
but I'm you know we both ignoring each
other kind of acting like we don't see
each other but then I see these two
[ __ ] and I'm like you can't help
yourself what's up with the [ __ ] and
I'm sorry talking to them part two these
These [ __ ] [ __ ]
cool I'm just putting myself in a line
of fire and it's the crazy [ __ ] we come
into the hotel 10 Deep everybody going
to the elevator for me to show them
where the room at except me so they are
out because I understand these [ __ ]
now I'm trying to talk to these [ __ ]
and next thing I know one of the [ __ ]
came out the blue he's like man this
[ __ ] ain't got no heater on them right
now we about to beat this [ __ ] up I was
like what [ __ ] what's up
start trying to talk my gangster [ __ ]
and then one of the homies actually came
in that didn't come in the group with
Ella but he came in he started trying to
break it up like leave it alone Danny
come on come on he did break it up he
did break it up and then
um I'm like you know just the drunk
courage something in me [ __ ] that [ __ ]
these [ __ ] and I run back up in there
Square my [ __ ] up I don't know what
happened all I remember a [ __ ] face
just got close to mine like he did like
Michael Jackson
[Laughter]
waking me up it was statues bro
I had a Timberland tree in the middle of
my head
in the morning looking in the mirror
like this life ain't funny
I want to go back to school I think I
need to I think I need a doing job
chorus
so yeah so they whooped me bad and uh so
I always had the grips with these [ __ ]
and I'm like yeah I see them [ __ ]
again it's home yeah working the
registry one day I got the big ass [ __ ]
with me this [ __ ] locked up he's the
guy who put the Timberland on your head
one of them yeah yeah yeah but he's like
the main guy he's like the most popular
guy with the crew so now I see him his
name is Jason
in here so I see the [ __ ] but I didn't
plan it out too good part two you know
Cartier glasses yeah that's like a big
Staple in Detroit yeah he's in the jail
cell with his Cartier glasses on that
right there should have gave me a sign
lead this [ __ ] alone it's no possible
way he got his car they put to take the
cardies from you so he wants some status
[ __ ] to even had the cardies he's
sitting in the cell with the cardi Zone
and he's by himself too I fake it off I
go get a push broom I go get the push
broom
and I'll fake it like I'm gonna go in
there and clean as hell and [ __ ] and you
know it's cameras everywhere so
everybody can watch it so as soon as I
get in the sale try to hit the [ __ ]
with the broom you know what I'm saying
like on some [ __ ] I try to hit the [ __ ]
with the pro this [ __ ] did some chat
Lee [ __ ] they caught the Broom
the [ __ ] caught me caught the broom and
gave me three stiff [ __ ]
[ __ ] man straight to the nose
I just I dropped the broom it just ran
[Laughter]
come on
[Laughter]
again
[Laughter]
it's a different weight class
so yeah I think our beef ended there man
it's over with okay good so Jason's good
in your book because I ain't got no
smoke with that [ __ ]
I learned my lesson did he get
cigarettes while he was in jail at least
no I ain't giving that [ __ ] [ __ ]
he probably did now all right so you get
out of jail right and you got confidence
now you know you could run some [ __ ] he
got to be dead in jail
he gonna see this [ __ ] coming for you